three months until the election a virus
coursing
through the country an ailing economy
and a future
without tick tock america's got its
hands full
but it will still always find the time
and the cash
to do a deep dive into russian
disinformation
the kremlin bears direct responsibility
for cultivating these tactics and
platforms
as part of its approach to using
information as a weapon
it invests massively in its propaganda
channels its intelligence services and
its proxies
to conduct malicious cyber activity to
support the disinformation efforts
and it leverages outlets that masquerade
as new sites or research institutions
to spread these false and misleading
narratives
a new report by the state department has
zeroed in on russia's
complex network of fake news and
propaganda
and basically it turns out like some
kind of mutilated octopus
there are five pillars to russia's
disinformation ecosystem from
the government itself to social media
but the one that gets the
most attention are our news sites which
apparently are really busy
peddling conspiracy theories but you
would never suspect them of being
nefarious
200 300 000 monthly views
a wide range of political topics and a
fairly quiet
twitter account but no it turns out it's
all
the kremlin in disguise
we found that they promote this
information in support of the kremlin's
goals
they're often promoted directly by the
russian government
and they push specific disinformation
narratives that are picked up
by other parts of the ecosystem how
intriguing some might say
tell me more others would cry well the
state department might say there's no
evidence of direct ties with moscow but
here's an unrelated example of an
alternative news story
to stop you from asking questions
the head of global research has written
many articles on kovid 19
containing disinformation one of them
that was published back in march
the headline of this is covid19
coronavirus
a fake pandemic who's behind it global
economic social and geopolitical
destabilization
so from that headline calling it a fake
pandemic
i think we all recognize it's not a fake
it's real you know now that i think
about it
i know the perfect person could
contribute to the site
it will go away just stay calm view this
the same as the flu a lot of people
think that goes away in
april with the heat coronavirus
they're politicizing it the report also
says that the same site suggests that
coronavirus was man-made in a
bio-warfare laboratory
you know now that i think about it i
know another person who would just be an
invaluable member
of this website's team i can tell you
that there is a significant amount of
evidence that this
came from that laboratory in wuhan with
the u.s battling
so many problems you could ask why
release the report now
well it could be a coincidence or not
but last week secretary of state mike
pompeo went with a begging bowl before
congress asking for a significant
increase in funding for the gec
which happens to be the author of this
report
the state department's fy 2021 request
for the global engagement center is 138
million dollars more than double its
current level
we won't tolerate disinformation and
other propaganda directed by the kremlin
or any of our other adversaries double
the budget for the sake of
a handful of relatively unknown news
sites averaging 200 000 monthly viewers
while solid reasoning all i can say is
that pompeo is going to have to get a
much bigger bowl when he sets his sights
on our team with it's it's not a
competition of course but
130 million monthly viewers but mike's
not all take oh no
no he's willing to give too the state
department's
rewards for justice program is offering
a reward of up to
10 million dollars for information
leading to the identification
or location of any person who acting at
the direction
or under the control of a foreign
government interferes with u.s elections
so mike tell me what's a gal got to do
to get their hands
on that 10 million
you